welcome to cloud security basics a new
series where we explain the ins and outs
of securing your application on Google
cloud sound fun then stick around
because in this episode you'll learn
who's responsible for securing what in
your cloud app
[Music]
a little cloud detective today I'm not
issuing a challenge only a riddle for
you
what do you have to do to secure your
cloud environment by yourself okay
here's what we know when it comes to
securing their cloud environments
enterprise companies care about a few
things consistently delivering the right
service and the right data to the right
identity this can't be something that
only happens some of the time it needs
to happen for every single request
implementing authorization and
authentication to make sure that only
the right people have access to
resources and data proactively
preventing threats because bad actors
are constantly evolving and effective
cloud security allows you to be
proactive rather than just reactive
complying with regulatory requirements
of their industry not all but more and
more businesses are required to be
compliant so that's something you have
to be aware of and flexibility and
control so internal teams can be
empowered to act on the parts they're
responsible for and can control to make
sure those areas are covered we must
heart in our cloud security securing
your system falls into three main levels
of responsibility things you're
responsible for things your provider is
responsible for and things you're both
responsible for there's platform
infrastructure and application level
security the user is responsible for
securing their applications like setting
up proper authentication authorization
and identification for users in their
system Google Cloud old securing the
platform which includes managing the
physical machines and data centers your
application and data use
lastly infrastructure security is a
shared responsibility where Google cloud
provides tools to help the user manage
their VMs network and data access needs
let's explore this in death so what do
you have to do to secure your cloud
environment by yourself hmm
I know that within these levels of
responsibilities there are three main
security actions you can take to heart
in your system platform and interactions
preventative actions and forensic
actions let me explain infrastructure of
form actions or steps you take to make
sure the underlying hardware or virtual
hardware are secure there are two
components of this platform security
which Google completely manages and
infrastructure security which is managed
by the user but Google Cloud provides
tools to help platform actions our step
Google takes to secure the hardware and
software tools available over the
Internet they provide users this can be
anything from physically securing data
centers to replicating data across
regions to make sure it's available even
in the event of a natural disaster
somewhere infrastructure actions on the
other hand our steps the user takes to
secure the cloud-based pay-as-you-go
services such as storage networking and
virtualization that Google provides this
could be anything from changing settings
and a load balancer to selecting a more
secure VM instance type for your
application the next class of actions
preventative actions these are steps you
take to avoid breaches like locking down
access controls much of this happens at
the application level and includes
things like Google Cloud Identity and
Access Management or I am and Google
identity aware proxy or I ap to limit
who has access to what inside of your
system so Google provides tooling to the
users to help define access levels and
then there are forensic actions these
are the steps you take to track down
breaches and stop them quickly or
ideally so identify and stop malicious
behaviors before a breach ever even
occurs one of the main practices here is
logging and monitoring by logging
activity within your system and setting
up automatic and manual monitoring of
that data you can be alerted as
suspicious activity before it's too late
here again Google cloud provides tooling
to help customers monitor their
environments that's it that's the answer
to Brad's question hello detective I see
you solved my little riddle what do you
have to do to secure your cloud
environment by yourself I said by
yourself that was tricky but here's the
thing you were never alone honest
cloud security is a shared
responsibility model Google handles most
of the infrastructure security but you
are ultimately responsible for securing
your applications and services that run
on that infrastructure you can never
assume an application or service is a
hundred percent secure but by leveraging
tools that focus on detection and by
planning for recovery you're ensuring
your security model has a chance at
keeping your service safe very good very
good you've solved my little riddle this
time but be ready because next time I
want to see what you'll do the wrong
identities access your data so there you
have it the first episode of cloud
security basics next episode will focus
on the first of three distinct areas of
cloud security risk access in the mean
time if you want to take a deeper dive
into the cloud security model then check
out the article linked in the
description below and stay tuned for the
rest of the cloud security basics series
because when it comes to security you
can't let bad actors win
[Music]